President Trump looks happy today it's
not because Putin finally accepted his
Facebook friend requests it's because
his two favorite things Twitter and live
TV are merging I don't know why the
Twitter but always just looks like
someone put a finger up its ass tweet
tweet
Twitter just announced that it plans to
stream live TV 24 hours a day guys
because they you don't see the reactions
like I why would they do they want to be
100 percent sure that they occupy all of
your attention while pooping I don't
know why they're doing it
Twitter Twitter CEO said their goal is
to become something always in the
background of people's daily lives like
CNBC and airports or or maybe may be
wondering if Carla was the one for you
and maybe you made the biggest mistake
your life this whole time getting on
that plane I mean sure you love Barbara
and you've been through a lot of stuff
together but she isn't about passion
it's all about maintenance at this point
and you have needs too what about your
needs so why don't so Twitter is making
a big gamble with this content shift by
suing that their audience has the
attention span to follow anything longer
than a hashtag brave picture of Demi
Lovato's face so comedians what's one of
the shows that we might see on Twitter
TV Henry the real dank memes of
Tallahassee boy okay say yes to the
blessed yes point
Maria Bamford NCIS Twitter 144
characters per episode yeah